Новини «heute» з Барбарою Гальвеґ.
Добрий вечір,
і дякуємо, що проводите його з нами.
З вами я, Барбара Гальвеґ, та Руді Церне з
черговою порцією спортивних новин.
Добрий вечір.
Сьогодні поговоримо про наступне:
Успіхи Росії на Сході:
Україна втрачає ще одне місто на Донбасі
та наполягає на постачанні важкої зброї.
Вугільна енергетика поступово відходить у минуле:
Великі промислові країни в пошуках
екологічніших альтернатив -
Німеччина та США змагаються за лідерство
в перспективному енергосекторі.
Проблеми з дебетовими та кредитними
картками: через програмну помилку
по всій Німеччині обмежено безготівкові розрахунки.
«Допоможіть нам закінчити цю безглузду війну» -
українці в розпачі закликають світову спільноту
не лишатися осторонь.
Однак наразі питання війни
залишається відкритим.
Росія продовжує звинувачувати Україну в
гальмуванні переговорного процесу.
Президент України стверджує, що Росія ще вочевидь
не готова до серйозних мирних переговорів.
Тим часом російські війська продовжують свій
наступ на сході України.
Далі - Франциска фон Тізенгаузен.
Україна втратила контроль над містом Лиман.
На цих записах з мобільного телефону видно,
як українські воїни під обстрілами залишають місто
на півночі Донецької області.
Проросійські сепаратисти повідомляють,
що захопили Лиман.
Інформацію, однак, ще не було
офіційно підтверджено.
Лиман є стратегічно важливим транспортним вузлом.
Захоплення міста може допомогти російським солдатам
просунутися до Слов'янська та Краматорська,
що наразі знаходяться під контролем України.
Далі на схід знаходиться місто Сєвєродонецьк -
одне з останніх міст Луганської області,
що лишається підконтрольним Україні.
Вже кілька днів місто перебуває
під постійними обстрілами.
Більшість з колишніх 130 000 жителів
залишила місто.
Ті, хто лишилися, шукають
захисту в темних та вологих підвалах.
Я намагаюся не думати про бомбардування та вибухи.
Я хочу, ні, я мушу якось пережити це все.
Російські війська наступають з трьох напрямків,
намагаючись повністю захопити
Донецьку та Луганську області.
Українська армія
знаходиться під величезним тиском.
Тому міністр закордонних справ продовжує
наполягати на необхідності постачання зброї.
Єдине, у чому ми поступаємося Росії,
це в кількості важкої зброї.
Без артилерійських систем,
без реактивних систем залпового вогню
ми не зможемо давати відсіч ворогу.
Російські війська вже захопили місто Попасна.
Однак після боїв, що точилися кілька тижнів,
від міста майже нічого не лишилося.
Від початку війни усіх одеситів турбує одне питання:
Коли війна прийде і до нас?
Місто-мільйонник знаходиться на узбережжі Чорного моря.
Одеський порт має стратегічно важливе
для України значення.
Російські війська перебувають на відстані
100 кілометрів від Одеси.
Цілком зрозуміло: у довгостроковій
перспективі Одеса – одна з головних цілей РФ.
Наш репортер Йоганнес Хано зараз в Одесі.
Про страх та готовність до боротьби -
далі в сюжеті.
Військові оглядають лінію горизонту через біноклі.
У хорошу погоду можна
побачити російські військові кораблі,
які курсують вдалині.
Зараз ми на одному з численних
блокпостів міста.
Тут військові готуються протидіяти
російській десантній операції.
Ще з початку війни ми готуємося до
російського наступу.
Щоденно зміцнюємо наші оборонні позиції,
посилюємо бойову спроможність.
Навіть якщо зараз в Одесі спокійно,
солдати вважають, що ця тиша оманлива.
Російські війська все ще вважають Одесу своєю
стратегічною ціллю.
Час від часу росіяни відправляють 20-30 дронів
для розвідки розташування наших позицій.
Кілька з них збили прямо в повітрі.
Російські безпілотники продовжують стежити
за оборонними спорудами ﻿та стратегічними об’єктами.
Українські спецслужби попереджають населення,
що військові кораблі та підводні човни біля узбережжя
оснащені сучасними крилатими ракетами.
Речник Одеської військової адміністраціїнаголошує:
не варто нехтувати елементарними правилами безпеки.
У місті небезпечно.
У будь-яку мить по місту можуть вдарити
крилатими ракетами.
Навіть тут, де ми зараз з вами стоїмо, небезпечно.
Одне знаю точно - ми не здамося,
ми обов'язково переможемо.
У місті регулярно лунає сирена.
Від початку війни ракети неодноразово влучали
в житлові будинки.
Мегаполіс на півдні України
є стратегічно важливою ціллю для Росії.
В українському Генштабі впевнені,
що Росія спробує захопити Одесу
для того, щоб позбавити Україну виходу до моря.
Якщо Росії це вдасться, російські війська
опиняться на румунському кордоні,
тобто на південно-східному фланзі НАТО та ЄС.
Втім, наразі нічого не вказує на
наміри Росії висадити свій десант в Одесі.
Але в Одесі готуються до приходу ворога заздалегідь.
Про просування Росії на Сході та українську армію
детальніше в ZDFheute liveо 19:30:
До вашої уваги репортажі з місця подій та інтерв'ю
з ексгенералом НАТО Еґоном Раммсом.
Шукайте рубрику ZDFheute live в додатку ZDFheute
та на наших каналах у соціальних мережах.
Міністерка економічного співробітництва та розвитку
Свенья Шульце прибула до Києва.
Вона стала другою депутаткою Бундестаґу, що
здійснила офіційний візит до України під час війни.
Вона відвідала містечко Бородянка,
що зазнало сильних руйнувань.
Пані Шульце запевнила, що Німеччина
готова долучитися до відбудови міста.
Міністерка повідомила, що вже було затверджено
185 мільйонів євро на екстрені заходи.
Ці гроші мають піти, зокрема. на відбудову квартир
та відновлення ліній електропередач.
Ще одна гаряча тема: глобальне потепління.
І хоча спинити цей процес нам вже не вдасться,
сповільнити його все ж можливо.
На саміті в Берліні
країни G7 домовилися об'єднати зусилля
задля спільної мети -
відмови від шкідливої для довкілля вугільної енергетики.
Щоправда, конкретних термінів визначено не було.
Далі - Патриція Відемеєр.
Саме індустріальні країни відповідають
за значну частину
світових викидів вуглекислого газу,
тому вони повинні та готові
робити більше для захисту клімату.
Це один із головних висновків сьогоднішнього
саміту G7 у Берліні,
що зібрав міністрів охорони навколишнього
середовища та енергетики.
Ми повинні зробити нашу економіку екологічнішою
та використовувати наші ресурси ощадливіше.
Країни G7 готові взяти на себе цю відповідальність.
Ми приймаємо цей виклик.
Декарбонізація, або відмова від викопного палива,
зокрема, вугілля, газу та нафти -
ось кінцева ціль.
Однак як саме її досягти - наразі не відомо.
Це завдання ще не закріплено на законодавчому рівні.
На саміті міністри домовилися
декарбонізувати енергопостачання до 2035 року.
Транспортний сектор
має відмовитися від виробників CO2 до 2030.
Для досягнення цієї мети країнам, що розвиваються,
щорічно асигнуватиметься 100 мільярдів.
Для того, щоб через двадцять років ми
змогли знову зустрітися та обговорити цю тему,
маємо діяти вже зараз,
а також в 2023, 2024, 2028, 2030 роках.
Лише Німеччина та Великобританія розробили
конкретні плани для подальшої відмови від вугілля.
Для природоохоронних організацій зустріч країн G7
стала важливим сигналом, однак:
Вони все ще не виконують
своїх обов'язків перед світовою спільнотою.
Країни G7 мають закріпити на законодавчому рівні
поступову відмову від вугілля до 2030 року.
А також з 2030 року має діяти заборона на
виготовлення та експорт
легкових автомобілів з двигунами внутрішнього згоряння.
США та Німеччина хочуть стати піонерами галузі
відновлювальної енергетики.
Вранці міністри підписали відповідні
заяви про наміри.
Проте не всі країни, що у великій кількості виробляють CO2,
взяли участь у саміті.
Зокрема, йдеться про такі промислові країни,
як Китай та Індію.
Після різанини в одній зі шкіл Техасу
думки американського суспільства знову розділилися:
можливо, варто переглянути закон про зброю?
Шанси на зміни в законодавстві, однак, мізерні.
У США більше вогнепальної зброї у приватному володінні,
аніж громадян.
Згідно зі статистичними даними,
на душу населення припадає 1,2 одиниці зброї.
Збройне лобі надзвичайно потужне.
Сьогодні в Техасі відбулася щорічна зустріч
збройних лобістів.
Далі - Клаудія Бейтс.
У Техасі триває підготовка до щорічних зборів
Національної стрілецької асоціації США.
З промовою виступить експрезидент США
Дональд Трамп,
усі присутні висловлять свої співчуття родинам
постраждалих у нещодавньому інциденті
та поскаржаться, що демократи використовують
стрілянину для своїх політичних інтересів.
Йдеться про більш жорсткий закон про зброю.
Лобісти, звісно ж, не підтримують таку ініціативу.
Де є поганий хлопець зі зброєю,
завжди має бути хороший хлопець зі зброєю,
який зупинить злочинця.
Зброя не вбиває. Вбивають люди.
Близькі загиблих у результаті стрілянини дітей
відчувають не лише скорботу, а й лють.
Батьки прийшли забирати дітей зі школи,
коли злочинець був усередині.
Згідно зі свідченнями, там стояли близько 40 поліціянтів,
але вони були бездіяльними.
Батьки благали поліціянтів врятувати дітей,
намагалися самостійно прорватися до школи.
Люди просили поліціянтів увійти до будівлі
та схопити злочинця.
Кожну хвилину зволікання
він відбирав чиєсь життя.
Щохвилини лунали постріли.
Але ніхто не хотів ризикувати власним життям.
Поліцейські не зайшли всередину.
Ці бідолашні діти не мали помирати.
Через дванадцять хвилин після дзвінка
перші поліціянти прибули на місце злочину,
проте, почувши постріли, вирішили не ризикувати.
Очевидці розповідають, що коли прибуло
підкріплення, їх не відразу пустили до школи.
Лише через 90 хвилин поліція нарешті втрутилася.
Зараз ми розуміємо, що це рішення було хибним,
і цьому немає виправдань.
Очільник поліції припускав, що злочинець
забарикадувався і дітям нічого не загрожувало.
Поліції доведеться відповісти на велику кількість питань.
У суперечці про незалежність судової влади
Польща робить крок на зустріч ЄС.
Парламент у Варшаві ухвалив рішення про розпуск
суперечливої дисциплінарної палати Верховного суду.
До її компетенцій входило
покарання та звільнення суддів.
Розпуск палати є обов’язковою умовою
для отримання фінансової допомоги для
боротьби з коронавірусом від ЄС
на суму близько 35 мільярдів євро.
Нова статистика страхової компанії DAK
продемонструвала, наскільки діти та молодь
постраждали ﻿від пандемії коронавірусу.
Згідно з підрахунками, у 2021 році кількість
стаціонарного лікування депресії серед підлітків
віком від 10 до 14 років зросла на 27%
у порівнянні з попереднім роком.
Кількість тривожних розладів зросла на 25%,
а кількість розладів харчової поведінки - на 21%.
Ще до пандемії клініки були переповненими,
а записатися до лікаря було майже неможливо -
і поки що ситуація лишається незмінною.
Навпаки -  в Німеччині працюють майже 420 тисяч лікарів.
З них понад 80 тисяч невдовзі вийдуть на пенсію,
попереджає Німецька медична асоціація.
Щорічно з університетів випускаються
близько 10 000 молодих лікарів,
які часто не готові до
такого великого навантаження.
Сабіна Комм розповість більше.
Не встиг пролунати дзвінок з реанімації, як треба
поспішати до наступної пацієнтки.
Саме в молодих спеціалістів, як і в нашої героїні,
часто виникає відчуття, що вони працюють
на межі своїх можливостей і, відповідно, не можуть
надавати належну увагу та допомогу своїм пацієнтам.
Лікарка-інтерн зменшила навантаження
і працює неповний робочий день.
Мені дуже подобається працювати лікарем,
і я хотіла б займатися цим у довгостроковій перспективі.
Я можу це робити лише тоді, коли почуваюся добре.
Я почуваю себе погано, коли працюю 60 годин
з надмірним навантаженням.
Згідно з опитуванням, 49% лікарів
часто відчувають виснаження.
Навантаження може збільшуватись.
Кожен п’ятий лікар незабаром піде на пенсію,
тому наступне покоління лікарів важливе.
Наразі ми вимагаємо помірну ціну за навчання
та збільшити кількість навчальних місць до 6 000,
тому що ми потребуємо колег, які в майбутньому
зможуть надати належну медичну допомогу суспільству.
Ми вимагаємо хороших умов праці для лікарів у
приватній практиці та клініці, щоб колеги не залишали роботу.
Це коштуватиме великих грошей.
Міністр охорони здоров'я Лаутербах відчуває тиск.
Проблеми чітко зрозумілі:
з одного боку це робота по змінах,
брак медичних працівників та суттєве перенавантаження.
З іншого - необхідність медреформи щодо оплати праці.
Якщо медреформа не набуде чинності,
то лікарка-інтерн змушена буде перейти в фармацію.
Але все ж їй потім не вистачатиме
найважливішого - контакту з пацієнтами.
Тепер до проблеми, яка виникає
в деяких супермаркетах, аптеках та на заправках.
Відсутні безготівкові розрахунки,
тому що не працює відповідна система.
Помилка програмного
забезпечення, яка виникла зненацька.
61,5% всіх покупок у роздрібній торгівлі
тепер здійснюються безготівково.
Несправні платіжні термінали
можна знайти в таких магазинах: «Aldi Nord»,
«Rossmann» та «Edeka».
Детальніше розповість Ганс Юрґен Піль.
Проблеми на касі як, наприклад,
в магазині товарів для активного відпочинку в Гамбурзі.
З вівторка у багатьох місцях
не працюють тисячі терміналів для оплати карткою.
Навіть великі суми можна сплатити лише готівкою.
Потрібно йти до банкомата.
Виникає питання,
чи вистачає грошей у банкоматі,
бо не скрізь можна оплатити карткою.
Така ж сама проблема виникла
в дисконтерах, на заправках та в аптеках.
Це зчитувачі карт старішого типу,
за допомогою яких більше не можливо
передавати дані постачальнику платіжних послуг.
Виробник не захотів надати конкретних пояснень.
На своєму веб-сайті він зазначає,
що розв'язання проблеми «в пріоритеті»
та незабаром надасть оновлення програмного забезпечення.
Експерти вважають,
що може пройти певний час, перш ніж це з’явиться всюди.
Ми припускаємо, що це займе деякий час,
оскільки йдеться про велику помилку,
яка потребує заміни обладнання на місці.
Це серйозна проблема для роздрібної торгівлі,
яка може призвести до падіння продажів.
Коли люди підходять до каси з товаром,
а потім дізнаються, що не можуть розрахуватися карткою,
вони обмірковують або йдуть, нічого не купивши,
і, якщо сумніваються, то здійснюють закупи в Інтернеті.
Поки невідомо, як довго не працюватимуть термінали.
Покупці таких магазинів повинні завжди
мати при собі достатньо готівки.
Вчора ввечері в Лондоні відбулась дивовижна
і досить моторошна прем'єра.
Через чотири десятиліття після останнього виступу
гурт «АВВА» з'явився на сцені у повному складі
або ж оманливі справжні «АВВАтари»,
які показують
тепер уже 70-річних шведських суперзірок молодими.
Глядачі були в захваті.
Андреас Штамм з репортажем із Лондону.
Прем'єра історичного значення.
Гурт «АВВА» возз'єднався через 40 років
для подорожі в часі у власне минуле.
Навіть шведська королівська родина прийшла підтримати їх.
Ми щасливі знову бути разом,
працювати разом.
Ніби прийшла додому.
Я дуже нервую
і дуже хвилююся,
хоча я ще цього не бачила.
Тут можна побачити музичне відродження,
оригінальні голоси,
їхні рухи - це «АВВА»,
але все це тільки світло.
Герої попмузики 70-х були відтворені голограмами.
Фантастичні анімації.
Ніби справді «ABBA» був на сцені.
Неперевершена вечірка.
Я не можу передати це словами.
Це зворушило мене до глибини душі.
Команда з майже 1000 людей створила «АВВАтарів».
Проекція гурту 1979 року.
За допомогою 160 камер тижнями
знімалися пісні з оригіналами.
Диджиталізовані та молоді.
Альбом ще  минулої осені, ймовірно, буде останнім.
«ABBA» точно ніколи більше не захочуть гастролювати.
Весь зал можна демонтувати
та звести в іншому місці.
На вічно молоде шоу в Лондоні чекає великий успіх.
Тепер Руді з новинами про теніс.
Анжелік Кербер вибула
з Відкритого чемпіонату Франції в Парижі.
На другому тенісному турнірі «Великого шолома»
німкеня програла Александрі Сасновіч з Білорусі
з рахунком 4:6 і 6:7.
Переможна серія Анжелік Кербер
завершилася після семи перемог поспіль.
Попри те, що вона досить добре подавала
та отримала кращий старт у другому сеті,
більшу частину гри вона не відбивала.
Вона не могла знайти свій ритм.
Враження, що вона майже здалася,
стало приводом для суперниці продовжити агресивну гру.
Бойовий дух з'явився надто пізно.
Я точно не виклалась на 100%,
я втратила багато енергії за останні кілька днів.
Однак я намагалась зробити все,
щоб відновити свої сили.
Вихід у 1/8 фіналу є найбільшим успіхом Сасновіч
на турнірах «Великого шолома».
На чемпіонаті Європи
з веслування на байдарках і каное в Словаччині
збірна Німеччини виборола золото у змаганнях на каное.
У другий день змагань тріо у складі
бронзового призера Олімпійських ігор Сідеріса Тасіадіса,
колишнього чемпіона світу Франца Антона і Тіма Труммера
перемогло в командному змаганні
випередивши Польщу та Іспанію.
Завтра ввечері на паризькому стадіоні «Стад де Франс»
відбудеться найбільше протистояння
в європейському клубному футболі.
Фінал Ліги чемпіонів: «Ліверпуль» проти «Реал Мадриду».
Також поєдинок між двома тренерами
Юрґеном Клоппом та Карло Анчелотті.
Деякі асоціюють відчуття туги з Парижем.
У спортивному плані це стосується
двох найкращих європейських футбольних команд.
«Ліверпуль» Юрґена Клоппа втретє за п'ять років
у фіналі прем'єр-ліги.
Суперник «Реал Мадрид» - рекордний чемпіон.
Незабутній фінал 2018 року, який «Ліверпуль»,
на жаль, програв.
Очевидно, я відчуватиму себе набагато краще,
якщо ми виграємо цього разу,
і зараз я думаю лише про те, як ми можемо це зробити.
Вигравши два національні кубки,
«Ліверпуль» може завтра завоювати свій третій титул у сезоні.
Завтра о 20:25 фінальний вечір у прямому ефірі на ZDF
та о 19:20 телепрограма «Champions League Magazin».
Найкращі результати – світовий рекорд
було встановлено вчора у Вітбі, на півночі Англії.
Там увечері  навколо руїн абатства
зібралося 1369 «вампірів».
Причиною цього стало те, що 125 років
тому вийшов роман «Дракула»,
частина історії якого відбувалася у Вітбі.
Кажуть, що автор Брем Стокер, надихнувшись візитом сюди
написав класику жахів.
Різноманітна та прохолодна - ось така погода на вихідних.
Наступного тижня ситуація знову зміниться,
детальніше з Катею Хорнеффер.
О 10 «heute-journal» з Марієттою Сломкою.
Дякуємо за перегляд,
бажаю гарних вихідних
і до завтра.
Добрий вечір.
Сьогодні хмари рухались
далі на південь від центру Німеччини.
Це був холодний фронт.
Цей холодний фронт ще не досягнув підніжжя Альп.
На півночі Німеччини пройшли зливи,
подекуди також грози.
Дощі та грози на півночі Німеччини
триватимуть до ночі.
Частково ясно,
невеликий холодний фронт досягне підніжжя Альп.
На південь від Дунаю цієї ночі - щільні хмари,
відносно помірна погода,
температура повітря від 12° до 10°.
Така ж погода і на Північному морі.
В інших місцях холодно - від 9° до 4°,
в низьких гірських хребтах навіть може виникнути
загроза повторних заморозків ґрунту.
Завтра протягом дня також буде холодно,
переважно від 13° до 17°,
на Середньому та Верхньому Рейні
температура підніметься до 18°-20°.
Завтра вранці біля підніжжя Альп може пройти невеликий дощ,
хмарно з проясненням.
Пройде сильний дощ з грозою.
Найсильніші зливи
із сильним, поривчастим північно-західним вітром,
ймовірно, очікуються між Берліном і Північною Фризією.
У неділю погода без змін.
Буде ще прохолодніше,
але з наступного тижня температура підвищиться.
Гарного вечора.